les archives nationales sont un trésor
précieux pour l'écrivain dany laferrière
c'est très important c'est la mémoire
d'un peuple c'est très intéressant de
regarder en bonne condition aussi sont
là pour durer le plus longtemps possible
créé en 1920 les hacher du québec
regorge de plus de 15 millions de
documents audiovisuels photographiques
cartes et autres documents darchy on y
retrouve entre autres ce portrait des
mini ligue ans ou encore celle ci
rassemble ans raymond lévesque edith
piaf paul berval et dominique michel
les archives c'est la caisse de dépôt du
savoir des québécois c'est aussi riche
que la caisse de dépôt dans un autre
domaine est notre avenir est là aussi
parce que dans l'ère digitale
c'est les boules et documents d'archivés
les collections d'archivés c'est un
vivier extraordinaire de données dans
ses voûtes
on retrouve également le testament
holographique de jeanne mance
cofondatrice de montréal ou encore un
plan de la ville de québec au début du
xviiie siècle
c'est sûr que ce sont des sources
primaires à cette époque de fausses
nouvelles
ça évite souvent quand on retourne aux
sources
on peut avoir davantage l'heure juste
sur certains événements
les archives nationales sont conservés
dans 10 centres répartis dans la
province ce qui les rend très accessible
les larmes généralement il faut les
garder dans la terre d'où elles viennent
pour que puissent grandir pour continuer
à faire une histoire qui est riche et
puis qu'on puisse apprendre de ce qui
s'est passé avant qu'ils continuent à
avancer une collection précieuse pour
les chercheurs et des scientifiques mais
aussi pour les curieux en général 50 %
des gens qui consultent et des documents
le font pour des recherches
généalogiques
les archives nationales nous permettent
de comprendre d'où l'on vient pour dc 10
où l'on souhaite aller quand on a stocké
sentant de comportement de manière de
regard sur nos autres eh bien je pense
que cent ans plus tard ça va être les
choses vont se répéter
d'une certaine manière avec des
variantes aune le québec se raconte à
travers ses archives et elles sont en
grande partie disponible sur le site de
bibliothèque et archives nationales du
québec
ici nabi alexandre chartier radio canada
montréal